the controller the algebra Curry Pro
right and we also have the um headphones
keyboard mouse and also the headphone
stand right yes because therefore yeah
and again all these are like suggested
to um compared to all with our um
you have the whole setup now the
question I have to do is back with the
prop like we know how long from the
early conceptual stages of the Ally to
to where we ended up here how about how
long was development we started the
whole thing about like five years ago
okay yeah cool cool so five years it
looks like um Microsoft has a Xbox One a
good presence on the device yes yes yeah
so there's that relationship kind of
synergized over time yes yeah so also we
see um the gap between because we have
everything from desktop to laptop laptop
to mobile right yeah and we see um
there's a gap between um laptops and the
phones yeah so we're thinking about like
having animal console would complete the
whole thing oh yeah no I love it I love
it this will replace the Steve deck and
again I'm seeing from the hardware level
this is the innards with all the parts
and everything very cool very cool stuff
you get to see the process in the very
beginning yes yes they've come together
yeah from panels
very cool very cool and then the device
itself which everybody seems to be
enjoying yes everyone seems to be having
a good time
very cool
we get some more footage on it
yes
um I had asked um what graphics card
slash cards are running at this
um so uh it's a rdna grade graphics
foreign
yeah it really depends on like what kind
of scenario you're using yeah so uh
um we're not allowed to share too much
performance data for now but um I would
say if you're
like a media consuming let's say like
Netflix or that kind of streaming
um the battery life would be enough yeah
okay I guess what about the hardcore
gamer the hardcore gamer the goddess
yeah you know these high performance
games with obviously rdna3 and running
yes yes yes yeah it certainly would be
um way shorter than the yeah yeah but uh
still I'd say it's um it's a it's
sufficient yeah also just from my
experience I was playing um Forza on the
performance mode earlier I mean I would
say my estimate was probably about two
and a half two and a half yeah
but what's impressive was um I noticed
again the Xbox integration The Game Pass
integration but the fact that it's
Windows 11 you can go native as opposed
to just being in a streaming setup which
is pretty impressive I think the scene
they're gonna be gonna have that right
now yeah yeah currently
um no yeah yeah it's interesting so
someone that you know down there you
have it hooked up to an actual monitor
um do you see this as a as a device that
people could almost use it's like a
makeshift laptop Yes Yes actually they
can yeah totally with the the Rog
accessories of course you can use it as
a
the last one yeah yeah as a desktop
feature
as far as like a storage configuration
you know yes I'm assuming it's going to
be maybe potentially different skus that
it may come in yes
but it's totally fine okay but I was
assuming maybe like a 512 maybe a one
Tera is it gonna be some for the for the
storage cost conscious person yes you
know will there be like a high-end
storage yes yes
um we've been testing um all different
kind of
um storages yeah and I think for now for
the U.S market I think uh the plan is up
to 512 gigabytes okay yeah but uh
certainly we already tested um one
terabyte and it also works fine so uh
and I'm assuming SSD nvme yes yes
um yeah um we only use um
yeah this time we don't have mem
solution oh okay guys and also it's uh
upgradable yeah it's a 2230
um the shorter version upgradable yes
yes yes yeah it's impressive okay yeah
you'll be able to open the bottom
chassis
you give the necklace configuration
options and then um I'm assuming this is
a Micro SD micro SD as well for
additional stuff yes yes yes and uh yeah
the the um SD card reader supports um uh
S2
um yeah so it's uh it's quite fast
actually we tested in our lab the game
installed on micro SD and the games are
installed on um SSD yeah the the launch
time is uh very very close yeah I'd say
like one two three seconds difference
yeah so uh yeah with micro SD card
reader is also a great way for expansion
gotcha so obviously you're going to have
any preferred solutions for as far as
the micro SD to get maximum performance
so you're leaving that up to the
consumer as far as okay giving that
flexibility that's cool illuminated
lights you see yes yeah yes yes very
very cool now for the battery conscious
could this be terrible
it's possible to turn it off yeah gotcha
yeah yeah yeah but uh yeah I think it's
uh it's nice and it is another question
in reference I know the white we talked
about it's Sleek you know will it also
come in like for example other color
models or just this is how you're
standing
um for now only the the white design
yeah sure gosh very cool very cool we've
got our fans going in the back and I'm
assuming
shifts yes yes yes all the buttons you
see on this device is uh mapable yeah
you'll be able to uh do like all kinds
of function and also macro yeah and also
um we can do like combo keys so um
you'll be able to use the M1A M2 plus um
different keys to set different so like
each key can like have two different
sets of different functionality yeah
yeah yeah and again these are these
buttons here but like kind of whether
they represent each one specifically I
noticed one kind of put me back to like
any profile yeah okay so so um these
ones are more like a regular Xbox
function this is like for system info
and this is like the the when you are in
game this calls out the the menu gotcha
yeah and these two are our own
um keys so this one is uh because um we
are a Windows 11 yes operating system so
um we optimized our Armory crate our
software to make it uh a console version
nice yeah so it's um it offers a better
console experience yeah so we have um
added some new features like um game
Library which um all the games installed
from different platforms like from Steam
from Xbox game pass yeah everything
would be like imports from this um game
Library so you'll be able to access all
games from different Platforms in one
place so for example like steam epic
store yeah yeah everything yeah and the
good thing about this because it's a
Windows 11 console so if you already
have those games on your PC you don't
have to buy them again oh that's right
because if you have that profile yes yes
you just log in and can start playing
yeah really cool and also in the setting
we'll be able to control the lights
um the key mappings and everything and
also we have uh this content platform
which um has uh like you can share your
screenshots and recording okay yeah and
so um like here again platforms you'll
be able to like log into everything here
yeah so this is a a new version of Rog
armor crate yeah we designed
specifically for this console yeah so
this this button is uh to quickly call
out the the armored crate
yes yes yes yeah and another one is um
this one so this is um called Command
Center so um when you're in game you'll
be able to use it as a quick quick
access menu nice yeah the stats a lot of
the gamers want to see yeah yeah
yes and you'll be able to like customize
all the functions here like if you want
to have a let's say screenshots or like
a performance mode or different kinds of
function you'll be able to set in our
armor crate yes yes as a quick access
menu that's very cool
and then I'm noticing on touch screen
right yes yes yes yes it's a touch
screen so uh yeah it's a seven inch
touchscreen and uh this is not only no
it's not the old lady yeah to save the
batteries actually yeah yeah and uh it's
uh 500ness Peak brightness 100 yeah and
uh four HD 120 hertz yeah so I believe
this is uh probably the the best panel
specification you'll be finding in the
market for this kind of gaming handhelds
yeah
and then just so can we can see like the
basic Windows 11
[Music]
so uh yeah as you can see it's just like
your regular pc Yeah so basically and
then from like from the adapter
standpoint
um will it will it come with like an
accessory for that person who wants a
traditional say they want to operate
this as a as a PC yes they're on the go
utilize it is there some type of adapter
interface that or accessory that could
kind of get you into that mode yeah
yes yes so um of course for the premium
experience yeah we have our XG interface
here yeah so uh we we used to have um
when we um we launched our XG mobile the
external Graphics earlier yeah I believe
like two or three years ago along with
the flow series laptop
so that's the time we create
um this part it's uh more efficient with
both type c and the the pcie by age Port
not sure yeah so all the extra mobile
um from the RTX 30 series one the
radiant ones and also the latest one
would be up to RTX 1490 so we could do
already including external with that yes
exactly the the ones we showcased there
with the Monitor and keyboard yes yes
that's when we we connected the RTX 1490
yeah that's the the very premium yeah
it's a very beautiful yes so for a
different talking wheels so um we'll
also launch a more simple one that is a
charging dock okay yeah so that one
supports um 65 Watts power delivery
we'll be able to charge the device with
that and also it has a Taipei port and
the HDMI port yeah so that one we
showcased at the the TV section yes yes
so you'll be able to connect to TV or
monitor with the yes yeah and also you
can use the Bluetooth function to
connect to either Gamepad or keyboard
mouse to the traditional color yes yes
that's cool as far as the battery option
is what I'm assuming the standard uh
plug kind of thing for a person for
example the article game who wants to
sometimes doesn't want to plug a little
bit like battery packs or anything like
that they can use their own standards
for that
um I think again
is the wattage is high enough you'll be
able to yes yes yeah so belonging up
that wattage compatibility yes yes yeah
cool volume rockers I'm assuming and uh
sensor
[Music]
um yes fingerprint sensor yeah supports
Windows hello yes
very cool on that point about
the what is for the processor yeah yeah
I don't think I'm allowed to share that
right now yeah yeah yeah
with the on-screen monitor yes I haven't
seen it go above um 30 watts and I know
that the switch maxed out at 39. yeah um
so is it similar to that do you would
you think or do you not review anything
no I cannot review it for now yeah but
uh but yeah I'd say uh with our thermal
solution yeah yeah we can definitely
yeah
you didn't realize that the uh like I
said the internal storage could be
upgraded that that's a huge yes yes yeah
we we use the the yeah the shorter 22301
Adobe Atmos yes yes don't be animals
yeah and also we have uh managed to fit
uh fuel speakers inside the system yeah
it's really cool and of course a
Bluetooth functionality like for example
if we wanted to get into those settings
for um like setting up your accessories
yes yes you'll be able to use the the
windows settings to to access those
functions when you're in that Armory
crate gamer profile yes yes yeah but I
think um for Armory crates we mainly do
um the aura lighting got it yeah you can
like sync all the lights together yes
yes yes yeah we saw with the games
you'll be able to to set all those yeah
very impressive very impressive so
they'll probably put a speaker on
potential release of all that stuff
later yeah and uh yeah of course you can
turn on turn off Bluetooth and Wi-Fi
using armor cred as well yes very
impressed very impressive thank you I
really appreciate getting some
additional information
on the Ally very cool let me know if you
have any more questions yeah thank you
so much no problem